[Music]
and back at the studio I mean there's a
chemistry there I can't explain it
shanon's so nice oh nice
Tim I don't know what to do I think you
should do whatever it is you're about to
do break up with her maybe I mean Lord
you get to hit them skins one last time
Oh Tim come on we do and we won't talk
like that I don't know it's this hats
changing me and throw it out
I tried hey Shannon listen I don't think
this is working
wait this is coming out of nowhere with
is there something wrong with the song
no well we did have to re-record the
song with Molly but it's only because
the the client thought there was no
spark in ours which is kind of my point
there's like no spark here what are you
gonna do spend the rest of your life
hanging out with Tim telling vulgar
highschool stories about your ass and
your testicles whoa whoa whoa whoa I
never said my balls came out okay
I mean they did got a huge laugh look
Shannon you're perfect but we are not
perfect for each other
yeah I don't think either I should
settle for anything less
[Music]
Sam
I just want you to know I never felt
like I was settlement I'd you know I
felt like I was settling damn it's and
I'm sorry
so uh boof no I'm sorry love you
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah